welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn wilshire host and our guest is
mush week Mubarak an associate professor
of economics at the Yale School of
Management he is a development economist
with interest in environmental issues
and has several ongoing research
projects in Bangladesh India Malawi and
Brazil professor Mubarak conducts field
experiments exploring ways to induce
people in developing countries to adopt
technologies or behaviors that are
likely to be welfare improving today we
talked with him about changing behavior
in developing countries welcome
professor mu bar thank you very much for
having me you have done I'm quite a bit
of research particularly in Bangladesh
tell us specifically about the work
you've done with clean stoves and
getting people to adopt stoves the
stoves are a good example of what you
just introduced as technologies and
behaviors that we think people ought to
be investing in but they have not been
so in this case the vast majority of
rural Africans and South Asians burn
biomass to cook with on very very simple
stoves it's three stones in Africa it's
usually clay stoves that they make
themselves in in South Asia and are they
using wood and wood would be the best
form of biomass but not everybody has
access to that just especially inside
that in South Asia where most of the
areas are deforested and so if you don't
have would you might burn cow dung but
even cow dung requires cows which is an
expensive asset so people end up burning
anything they find that's cheap so such
as crop refuse or hey things like this
or even dry leaves and branches that you
get in the winter and the smoke that it
produces when you burn these forms of
biomass it has very high concentrations
of particular matter and PM 2.5
particular matter less than two and a
half micrometers in diameter is what we
care most of us because the finer the
particles when you breathe it in it gets
lodged deeper in your
makes your lungs irritated and
susceptible to bacterial infections
which kills you and now the world health
organization claims this is a big
problem about it attributes about
twenty-two percent of all infant
mortality Wow to acute respiratory
infection which is related to this
indoor air pollution exposure so people
cook for 5 or other day in an enclosed
kitchen there's a lot of smoke there
breathing in and leads to lead to
infections so now the puzzle here is
given these enormous health consequences
you'd think that people would be
interested in purchasing improved
cookstoves or non-traditional cook
stoves which address the indoor air
pollution exposure but they have not
been so there have been stoves improved
stoves like this around for 25-30 years
that have been developed to be you know
context appropriate locally appropriate
for local fields and and and cooking
methods but people have not been
investing and it still costs ten to
twenty dollars and so that's the puzzle
that we're we're after ok so the these
stoves have been in existence for
basically a couple of decades are people
aware of the health consequences of the
stoves I mean I think that would be the
first obstacle sure so we studied that
so we conduct a series of field
experiments where we randomly assign or
very prices of stoves the information
you make available for people as and as
well as some other things that I'll go
on to describe okay and it turns out
that even if you even if you're not
making a connection between respiratory
infection and the stove that you're
cooking with it is the case that these
stoves are really unpleasant to work
with so the smoke it that produces burns
your eyes and I'm embarrassed to admit
it takes you know it's difficult for me
to stay in the kitchen for even five ten
minutes while especially well the fires
being stoked and their women were there
for several hours and the infants they
care for we're also in there okay so it
it's it's shocking to me given the
health issues and just the uncomfortable
conditions of cooking that way that they
would not convert I mean is the price
point in issue what it what have you
found to be the issue why are they not
adopting this technology sure so there
are several reasons I
think price is a big factor the
traditional method of cooking which is
stoves that people construct for
themselves with clay that's essentially
free if you'll know how to do it they
look there the material is locally
available and and it's really difficult
to compete with an outside option that's
free all right the price is definitely
an issue that's one of the key issues
but beyond that there are some other
interesting issues that we need to think
about because it turns out that even
when you offer these tools at very low
and highly subsidized prices even then
people are not taking them up and so why
is that and why is that yes so we
conduct experiments with men and women
separately in order to understand
whether there's a gender dimension to
this preference so for example it's
almost exclusively women who are cooking
and therefore this technology the new
technology is really gender specific
it's it really benefits the women and so
they may be they may have an interest in
investing in stoves however if they're
not the financial decision maker they
may not be able to act on that interest
I say and so you can have a situation
where the preferences within the
household across the husbands and wives
can actually differ and that might make
up take very low so to get at this so we
ran experiments in Bangladesh where in
some villages we offered one of two
types of stoves for free it's the one
with a chimney stove so that's really
easy to understand what it does it just
redirects the smoke out of the house and
then another one is as common as a
common design across the world is
something like an efficiency store which
makes a combustion more efficient it
reduces quitting time and fuel
consumption etc so that one is primarily
a budget saving stove so the first one
that chimney stove at the health saving
one and the second one budget saving one
and so that contracts is what allows us
to look at whether or not when men and
women have different preferences so in
one set of villages we go in in some
randomly chosen households we offer the
choice of either a chimney stove the
healthy stove versus the budget saving
stove for free and we offer that choice
to husband in some houses randomly
chosen in wives and other houses okay so
what did you find so there we find when
you offer the stove choices for free it
is the case that women
express a stronger interest in getting
taking any kind of improved stove and
conditional on taking a stove they have
a stronger preference for the healthier
stove it should may one exactly so it's
that's not surprising given what I just
said I mean are the ones who cook so the
problems are more saline for them
however what gets interesting is in a
different set of villages randomly
chosen we offer that same choice again
two husbands and wives separately in
neighboring hustles but this time we
start charging to the stove right and
what we find is even if you start
charging little bits of money of course
you know both men and women their demand
comes down because as I said price is
important however the women's demand
which used to be a much higher than men
actually falls below men's so they it
comes down a lot more right so the
combination of the two things of the two
villages helps us learn that while women
do have a stronger preference for the
stove when they can express that
preference because it's because been
giving for free when you start charging
for the stove even if you subsidize
eighty to ninety percent women can't
really act on that preference and they
can't act on it because they don't
control the purse strings is that
correct that's that's right so so there
is so budget constraints are an issue
but what you find from this research is
that the budget constraint is not at the
household level like how we normally
think about it there's actually a
separate budget constraint for the woman
we just separate from the men and their
constraint is a lot more stringent the
women's constraint right right okay so
ultimately what do you conclude with
this so this is a very difficult issue
now because you can't so I consult for
example with the Global Alliance for
clean cookstoves which is trying to
distribute 100 million stools by 2020
you're trying to get up taking 100
million storms and this is a US State
Department led led initiative now you I
can't really advise the Global Alliance
that you should go and market to women
because as it turns out while they want
the stove they can't really purchase it
they can make purchases that wouldn't
work but at the same time you can't say
go and market to men because they don't
even want the technology so the idea
have come up with like you catch 22
exactly it's a very difficult problem
solved so the idea so the idea of come
up with which we are now trying with a
new round of experiments in India is
that we should bundle something
that the men were men want along with
the technology that we're trying to get
the women to take what do they want um
yes that's a good one tasty food so in
this case I've now partnered with a
company called bio light which has a new
stove design where and this is a company
based out of New York so they've in the
process of generating heat they're still
design generate tiny amounts of
electricity alright and they've added a
USB charger to the side of the stove
right and so what you can do is bundle
say a simple USB charger for the nokia
cell phones the very simple cheap nokia
cell phones that are common in urban and
rural india and the idea is in villages
where electricity acts as a problem
which is still true in a lot of rural
india you could bundle this new
attribute which is a cell phone charging
capability and since it's men who
typically carry cell phones right when
you're in villages where they have a
hard time charging their cell phones
regularly or have to go to the town or
have to pay for cell phone charging this
is something that men might care about
and what's interesting with clever about
this idea is that you know you could
bundle something else that men one with
the stove I don't know maybe it's
cigarettes that they want all right so
you could just say here take a pack of
cigarettes with it but at the same time
you know men would react to that by
saying look I can just go buy the
cigarettes at the store myself why do I
need to take a stove with this all right
but what's clever I'd about this idea is
that that attribute the cell phone
charging capability cannot be unbundled
from the stove and it's not something
that men have easy substitute solutions
to so we're now trying trying out these
experiments in India to see how well
that works right so do you have any
inkling as to what will happen from that
research you have findings at this point
or no so the full set of experiments
have not yet been done however well
after our piloting we've learned that a
lot of the men actually talk about
getting say LED lights as opposed to
cell phone charging as as the key thing
that they'd want to charge with the with
the stove so we're also trying now
different variations of what what
product we'd want to bundle this
so some lights maybe a more attractive
option then okay i think that the
sticking point for me is if you tell the
husband look you're your wife and your
children are have serious health
consequences that that is not them the
driving factor here right so there's a
lot of research and development that
suggests that men do make very different
choices with money than women do and
that's that's true across generations as
well as other research that suggests
that we know when women have access to
funds there are a lot better health
outcomes and educational outcomes in
world school enrollment etc for for
children yes whereas men giving money at
the hands of men does not does not lead
to the exact same set of outcomes
there's research on South Africa said
that suggests that when grandmother's
get pensions that leads to better
outcomes for their grandchildren so men
and women do spend money differently I
think that's one of the issues but over
here the other issue in defense of men
is it's not necessarily that they don't
know what they don't care it's just that
because they're not in the kitchen the
problem is not a salient for them and
they are spending money on other things
and the issue is in these poor
environments in rural areas of
developing countries there are many many
competing interests competing demands on
very scarce funds well and I was going
to actually make that point because we
are talking about people who have very
very I mean they are poor basically it's
very very poor so um so even ten to
twenty dollars um you know that if you
get them to spend that money on the
stove that might they might not have
food to cook on the stove exactly or
they may not have money to buy textbooks
for their children or or being able to
access a clinic when they need to write
okay now you've also looked at seasonal
migration in Bangladesh during famine
season let's talk about that a little
bit sure so this is actually the
research was done in Bangladesh but this
is again a global problem spanning
across countries in Africa and Asia okay
and the issue is that in agrarian areas
where people are relying on
sure their income comes during the
harvest as you might expect which is
usually once a year or maybe twice a
year so in Bangladesh's January that's
when you have the main rice harvest and
the issue is that the pre harvest season
so after you've planted let's let's say
in August and then September to November
which is the pre harvest season there's
not that much to do there's a little bit
of agricultural work but during this
period you know you're just waiting for
the crop to grow and so employment
conditions are pretty bad and therefore
wages are also low there's a lot of
workers not enough jobs to be had right
and and so income is low but at the same
time unfortunately that's when the price
of rice spikes up possibly because it's
been the longest time since the last
harvest from last January right and so
this combination of high prices low
income leads to much lower caloric
intake which is what leads to a famine
in fact in about in Bangladesh in North
Bengal it happens every year and if it
has a name is called manga which roughly
translates into a period of high prices
so then you have the seasonal famine
that's expected that happens every year
and why you know the puzzle for me was
why can we not solve this why are people
still sitting in there and as I said the
problem is global so in other parts of
the world where I work like in southern
Africa this period is called the hungry
season people are expected to go hungry
in Indonesia there's a seasonal famine
it has a different local name but again
the same same issue in eastern islands
of Indonesia so they all the government
and in your efforts here were trying to
get trying to help people at you know
address the seasonality issue so for
example they might do targeted
microcredit or they might do food for
work programs or subsidized food
distribution which are all pretty
expensive things for a poor country to
do a government of a poor country to do
and also it has this perverse effect of
getting people to stick to where jobs
are not right to in order to get these
handouts right so my idea was can we
complement these government and NGO
efforts by allowing people to move to
where the jobs are there are some
structural reasons why jobs are not in
these Eric cultural areas it makes sense
that people live there come January
there'll be a lot of work with September
November it doesn't make sense that
people are still there and other
qualitative research suggests that in
nearby urban areas where you don't have
the same agricultural cycle because it's
not an agricultural economy you do have
work available so for example you could
go work at construction sites you could
go pull a rickshaw and provide some
transportation services okay so this is
basically a new idea because people have
not been doing this correct yes so
people I mean some people of course have
been migrating so the new idea here is
and the question that I asked is why are
more people not migrating and that's
what's new about this okay and what have
you found why are they not migrate okay
so let me let me first describe exactly
what I did and what their response was
and then we'll come back to this
question of why people are not doing it
so the experiments we ran here where I
went to a set of villages again it's a
randomized control trial so so some
villages randomly chosen we went and
offered equivalent about eight and a
half dollars conditional on one person
from the household migrating the
contract was you get this eight and a
half dollars if one person tries it out
you could go for three days take a
little vacation and come back and that's
fine with me but one person has to try
out seasonal migration to till the
furniture right we weren't offering a
job just right I'll look on your own and
like smart and it was eight and a half
dollars because that would cover the
round trip bus fare to nearby urban
areas plus a couple of days of food the
idea is I'm saying try it out and if it
doesn't work out you can come back and
you know we're soft because I'm covering
the because there's no negative to them
trying it it's exactly and the second
set of villages I offered this exact
same contract eight and a half dollars
but as a loan rather than a grant so
zero interest loan that has to be paid
back once the harvest comes back because
if you're going to scale this up you
know we wanted to see you know if it
works with as a loan rather than a grant
yeah because you can't give everyone
eight and a half dollars to exactly then
with the same limited budget we can
reach a lot more people behind us alone
right now all the thing is that when you
offer people money to migrate you have
to talk to them about migration while
you're doing this so we offer some
general information from surveys we
collected so for example these are the
cities you could go to these are the
sectors where you can find work and
these are the average wages in those
sectors right so I wanted to you know
it's possible that information might
have an effect as as you pointed out for
the stove case right that lack of
information might be
finding people from doing this and so in
a third set of villages I just offered
that exact same information using the
same script without offering the money
and that allows me to separate out is it
really a failure of information or is it
a failure of having enough money for a
bus fare right and then you have a
control group of villages where you're
not doing anything but you collect the
same data and track migration to have a
comparison point for that here right and
what you find first is when you provide
just information there's no effect so in
the control area thirty five point nine
percent of people migrate when you
provide information 35.9 percent of
people migrate so it wasn't that people
were uninformed that migration is a
possibility and if you think about it if
a third of households are migrating in
your village you know somebody is going
and therefore you know that it's
possible right so that's not what's
preventing them from doing it right but
then when you offer loans or grants
that's when it gets interesting the
migration rate jumps to about fifty
eight fifty nine percent Wow so you can
induce almost a quarter of the
households to try this out right and
then the second result is I then track
what the effects of migration are and
now that i have i randomly induced
migration in certain areas i can track
very carefully exactly what the causal
if that's the migration are and what you
find is if you are induced to migrate by
the program then your family remaining
in the origin your wife and children so
because it's a dolt male who's going
they consume about 600 calories per
person per day more which is a huge
effect it's the difference between two
meals a day and three meals a day for
during this time in season and how is
this where does this come from a lot of
it is coming from the fact that the
migrant is at the destination and has a
job and takes care of himself and we
track people at the destination and the
migrants end up earning on average about
a hundred and ten dollars during the
two-month period and then how much is
that in comparison to what they normally
earn during the harvest season right so
the during the heart that's a difficult
question to answer because during the
harvest season at the origin the problem
is not earnings but much more lack of
job opportunities but you know that's
600 calories is really what allows us to
say that this is better than staying at
significant yeah because we are able to
debt 600 calories is off of a comparison
to what people staying at home we're
doing versus what people going
I have got a question about the loans
where some people hesitant to take the
loan for fear they would not be able to
pay it back definitely so the take-up
rate was slightly lower for the loan
than it was for the for the grant and
the other thing okay so is that
ultimately eighty percent of the people
were able to pay back the loan and so we
and this is what allows us to learn
something about exactly why people were
not doing it doing migrating to begin
with so i gave you average effects 110
dollars on average but it turns out not
everybody was successful right the
majority of people did find work and
based on the data we can characterize
maybe seventy five eighty percent of
people and that they were successful
that this was a sensible thing for them
to do which which relates well to this
eighty percent loan repayment rate that
I just gave you right but for twenty
percent of people there is this risk
that look you go somewhere you don't
find a job then you have to come back
empty-handed alright they weren't used
to go with our program because we said
we'll cover that cost and that that you
know that discovery phase so so
essentially this this then allows us to
learn exactly what was going on right
although to to tell the full story I
should I should continue telling you the
sort of long-term effects of this so so
I've said so far that many people are
induced to migrate and when they migrate
they earn quite a bit and they and they
conceive and their families consume more
and then the next year 2009 and then
three years later in 2011 so I went back
and in a subset of villages I did not
repeat the program I just continued
collecting data just to track in the
long run what happens here and the
striking thing that happened is that in
the treatment villages that were induced
to migrate with money back in two
thousand eight in two thousand nine and
twenty eleven people continue to migrate
at higher rates than the control
villages right because they it was
proven to them that they were able to
find work so not everybody went back
would we see who went back it's exactly
related to the people who were
successful back in two thousand eight so
just over half the people chose to go
back again and you see that people who
are successful chose to go back and then
some other one other data point that
helps us learn what's going on here is
that in 2011 we asked the people who
went back whoo-hoo their employer was
and for the vast majority of people they
reported that back in two thousand eight
the employer that they met were the ones
that they were still working for oh good
so the asset that they grew here is a
connection to an employer right which is
the employers saying okay you've now
proven yourself that you're a reliable
worker so come back next year and i'll
give you the same job right and that's
what induced them to go back and so that
so this all of these data together helps
us build a story as to what was going on
and so as an economist then we write a
model that's inspired by these by these
data points and the model is as follows
so imagine that I give you a lottery
ticket all right and I say you know
about seventy five eighty percent of the
time it'll pay off okay and when it pays
off you'll get like a four hundred
percent return okay would you like that
lottery ticket yes yes it looks like a
it sounds like a really great deal yes
and and so that's the puzzle here you
know the migration is like a lottery
ticket like that seventy five to eighty
percent of the time it pays off and when
it pays off it pays off big and so the
puzzle is why are people not buying that
here's the thing are you giving me the
lottery ticket or am i buying a lottery
ticket you're buying it okay it depends
on how much that lottery ticket cost
sure would be my answer sure so it costs
in this case it's ten dollars right and
and so that's actually still a good deal
because the cost is low right however
now imagine that I'm offering that's low
for me but I don't know if it would be
fair that I mean it the price point will
vary depending on who you're talking to
right so imagine now that I offer you
that lottery ticket when you really
close the subsistence and your families
under the threat of famine right so even
though you can make that ten dollars
into fifty dollars with high probability
right so even for a poor person that's a
pretty attractive deal with a very high
probability that n becomes 50 but if the
ten dollars does not pay off that small
chance of twenty percent chance that it
doesn't pay off then that the cost of
that happening might be devastating
right because you're very close to
subsistence you're barely surviving and
if your ten dollars poorer that might
actually put you below subsystems and
something devastating happens in your
family right and so even though it's an
attractive option it's an attractive
risk to try out right and people should
normally be taking advantage of
opportunities like that that are risky
it's really difficult to make that
decision when
close to subsistence the issue is that
you know it's only ten dollars per that
you that you might become but the
utility cost of that might be enormous
maybe just devastating so now moving
forward how is this going to help the
people of Bangladesh for instance what
what are you planning so if the story
that I just constructed with that it's a
little bit of a lottery but people are
very very risk averse and as they ought
to be it's a fear of failure that
dominates their thinking if that story
is correct then that actually suggested
the way I ran the program with the grant
and the loan was not the right way to
run it all right it suggests that people
were not migrating not because they
needed a grant or alone but because they
need an insurance they needed it was a
fear of failure that was preventing them
doing it therefore what I should really
be doing or what government policy
really should be about is covering them
for their downside risk right so how do
I provide insurance and this is what I
ended up going back and doing in 2011 ok
so here now you offer them say you offer
them ten dollars from migrating and you
have a new type of contract that says
ten dollars try out migration if it
works out and everything's good you need
to pay me back 15 to cover the insurance
premium but if it doesn't work out you
don't find a job then you don't need to
pay me back or you can just pay me back
five something like that right and and
so that has the seed that has a
characteristic of insurance because the
payoff is dependent on like how good the
outcome was which is exactly how
insurance works right if a car accident
happens you get a payout if it doesn't
happen they keep your premium right it's
the same idea here right and and so we
went back and offered this contract and
it was even more popular like when the
contract was designed well it was it was
even more attractive right and this is
even less expensive for a government
policy sort of to implement just because
it's a on average this you know this
contract may be a 20-percent part of the
population who will not be able to find
work exactly so now is as policy being
formed around this right so so there are
some issues that we have to work out so
for example you can't really just offer
an insurance contract that says
you don't need to pay me back if things
don't work out because in that case it
won't work out for anybody all right so
we instead the way we do this contract
is I say okay if there's a lot of
rainfall in Bangladesh there's a lot of
flooding risk as many reviews well know
right so there's a lot of rainfall and
there's a flooding risk I'll measure
that and if that happens then you don't
need to pay me back but if it's a normal
amount of rainfall than you then you do
so so since then so now the research has
is about to be published and we've you
know gone through the peer review
process and we think that we have you
know something here and the results are
rigorous that right invincible it sounds
great and so now we you know now you
know being confident we go to government
and we and and to NGOs and we try and
get scale up for the research I'm doing
this using multiple avenues so another
hat I we're outside of the Yale
professorship is is as a lead researcher
for a Bangladesh research program funded
by DFID the UK government foreign aid
arm and and it's called the
international growth centre and our
mandate there is to create more
internationally and policymakers end and
academics like myself searchers yeah
right so we invite policymakers and so I
invited the Minister for food security
disaster management to come to London to
hear this hear hear about this work and
then discuss it so just to see the idea
that a part in addition to food for work
programs or food distribution you ought
to be thinking about migration as
another policy response right so we've
managed to and did he embrace that idea
so I think the government is is is a I
wouldn't say yes because the government
is really you know risk-averse so they
want to proceed carefully and they want
to see more data and repetitions of this
and other people in other countries so
for example ausaid and Indonesia was
very convinced by the research so they
are now trying this out in Indonesia so
trying to encourage migration from the
eastern islands of Indonesia to to Java
aware which are the employment centers
and the large NGO with with with whom we
worked in in Bangladesh you know who
helped us actually design and implement
these contracts so Dave liked the idea
and
it has there and this teacher is
something about how to get government
and sort of policymakers to respond when
we work with this large NGO you know
this project and the research results
already have their stamp on it so they
were much more embracing of the other
concept so we are now working with them
for them to design a migration loan
contract so normally they do this
standard microcredit contract where you
have to repay every two weeks and when
you have to repay every two weeks you
can't really leave in my grade because
you have to stay back and pay right so
we're now helping them design a contract
which is going to be a migration loan
contract a small amount where the
repayment period would be four months
rather than two weeks right so they have
embraced that and we're not looking for
funding to try and scale that up
wonderful well you're doing such great
work thank you for being here with us
ensuring thank you very much and thank
you for your interest in the work for
more information about professor mubarak
and his research please visit our
website at Yale that edu / Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you